our next guest started his radio career
in los angeles over 20 years ago and has
since become the voice of la
and just last week he became a permanent
part of la history by receiving his star
on the hollywood walk of fame
please welcome
big boy
[Applause]
thank you thank you
um
did you ever think
that you would have a star on the
hollywood walk of fame no you know as a
kid growing up i never thought of
that you know i've been to hollywood
hollywood is one of those places where
you walk down the street and you look at
those stars but
i've never walked down the boulevard and
said i'm gonna have one of those you
know as a kid growing up drew i was like
i had big dreams and i would always tell
my mom always say oh mom you know one
day i'm going to be famous one day i'm
going to sign autographs and my mom
never deflated anything
at
we were homeless
and seven kids my mom and i told i said
mom one day i'm gonna buy you a house so
you won't have to be we wouldn't be
evicted again she said baby i know you
will
and i felt like i wanted to be the
person that took care of my mom and took
care of my family and when i got into
radio i was able to buy her that house
that i told i would purchase her when i
was a kid she never got you know
thank you thank you
i've followed your career my whole life
because i listened to you on the radio
what was that first gig like what was it
like to hit the big time and can you
talk about the music of that time
because that also
is
so much a part of the dna of who i am
that time
is one of the best times i believe in
music history yeah yeah
getting into
getting into a
radio for me i started at power 106 in
1994. i knew some guys by the name of
the baker boys you probably remember the
baker boys early in the morning and with
the bakers i was just friends and i
never thought oh let me you know i can
get a job here i can get a job their
boss called me up one day and asked me
if i wanted to try radio for one for one
night four hours
thirty five dollars an hour i'm thinking
like oh okay i'm just doing the math not
the career i'm doing the math like okay
what's that a hundred okay and i do the
math i go i get the second that he calls
me the next day i get the second day now
at this time drew
i'm over at that time i'm probably like
450 500 pounds that's where the name big
boy comes from i was over 500 pounds
that's right and so i thought about it
and i said well let me just try this
radio thing so i went and tried radio
and that was 27 years ago
you know
and
and with the music i was a fan of the
music so in 1994 i'm going in
playing people that's from l.a i'm
playing snoop dogg i'm playing dr dre
yeah i'm playing ice cube you know that
was the time of music
um and even earlier like i was really
into grandmaster flash i was really into
strafe money love slick rick epmd oh
yeah public enemy oh you got a hip-hop
car oh i mean if we move this out the
way she probably started pop-locking and
break dancing
this this is what we grew up on and it's
it formed me and i liked putting
images to music and as a filmmaker and a
producer
and certainly we fell in love with the
director named mcgee who had no credits
to his name except for music videos and
i went to sony pictures and i was like
you know us kids that you're trusting
your hundred million dollar charlie's
angels movie with well we'd love this
guy to direct it his name is mcgee and
they're like
he has done music videos and i was like
i know and he's the only one who gets
the tone of the movie
we want to make and
uh i'm so proud to say that you are in
one of the charlie's angels you're in
full throttle we have a photo of it
right here hello and uh
just it was so fun to work with you then
it's a pleasure to be with you now
congratulations on your star on the walk
of fame the streets
that you
with hopes and dreams proving that hopes
and dreams do come true and we also know
that you just had a birthday and uh to
celebrate your birthday uh we have a
little something for you
thank you so much
um
i just want to say um i'm so happy for
you
and i've just been one of your biggest
fans for so long i have been a big fan
of yours as well oh you know that
thank you
oh my gosh i'm just this is so fun for
me okay big boy congratulations and
happy birthday to you be sure to check
out big boys new show after hours with
big boy
starting on october 7th on a new
platform looped in
[Music]